the left is reintroducing the same
segregation that they had decades ago
twice as many white people are killed by
blacks as the other way around and we're
not oppressed
we're not oppressed we are being
manipulated
i say the fact is that i've done more
for the black community than any
president since abraham lincoln i'd say
it nobody can disagree with
[Applause]
about the it virus that they're giving
this propaganda
to all the american people and stealing
fear and fear mongering
is more people die from the food more
people die from diabetes from
obesity from cancer than the coronavirus
ever what we are talking about and what
they are after
are marxist principles they are right
now
teaching in school critical race theory
most homicide is same race homicide but
to the extent that there is
black white white black homicide last
year there were 750 500 whites were
killed by blacks
250 blacks were killed by white
we are not afraid of the police lebron
james you are lying and deceiving the
truth is not in you
we're not oppressing these times for
somebody to speak against black lives
lives matter
[Music]
they know nothing they're clueless
they're angry that's all it is they're
just
angry and they want to they want to just
lash out
i'm opening that i'm not doing it now
turn it to venezuela
if you don't like this country you can
leave you can go drop the mic